the machine gun has long been an iconic
entry to the most Blockbuster of action
movies and an essential part to any
video game Arsenal for decades
but as games have advanced it can
sometimes feel like the lmg has been
left behind so what then is the virtual
Legacy of the light machine gun why is
it that so often it feels more like a
souped up assault rifle rather than a
belt-fed banger
thank you
foreign
so many light machine guns and games
feel like a different beast when
compared to the real-life versions
they're built around but to break down
their virtual lives we must also take a
look at their real world role and how
they're actually used broadly speaking
an lmg is simply a lightweight machine
gun that can be operated by a single
person with or without an assistant that
can be carried with the user forward
into action and often utilized for
suppressing fire from a bipod in support
of the user's Squad
but these weapons have come a long way
and lost a lot of weight since the
Inception of the machine gun over 100
years ago in 1884 Hiram Stevens Maxim
invented the first practical
self-powered automatic machine gun the
Maxim gun by modern standards we would
call the maxim a heavy machine gun as it
was indeed heavy and required a team to
operate and a platform to be mounted on
Fast Forward 20 or so years to 1903
where French military theorists saw that
during assaults the machine guns they
had were of little use as they were
unable to be brought up alongside the
attacking infantry they determined that
the machine gun must learn to walk the
classifications that we have today of
light medium and heavy machine guns are
somewhat modern although by the first
world war we had created the category of
the light machine gun it might be called
something else I think the lowest gun
was known as the light automatic gun at
one point but the key the key point was
that it was portable something that a
single soldier could operate even if it
was designed to be operated by two the
other mainly carrying and loading
ammunition for the shooter but a two-man
team as opposed to a five or six man
team for something like a well any of
the maxim pattern machine guns pretty
quickly just about all the forces in the
first world war realized they would need
something lighter to allow them to be
more Dynamic with their Firepower the
Germans adapted the maxim into the
machine Governor 08 or mg08 and then
adapted that into the lightened mg0815
with a shoulder stock and pistol grip
while the British purchased the American
Lewis gun moving their heavier Vicar's
machine guns into a dedicated machine
gun core and issuing the new Lewis gun
to a battalion's gunner teams by the end
of world war one there was already a
variety of light machine guns from belt
feds to magazine fed and even a broad
selection of calibers
the advantages and utility of the lmg
were cemented into the world's Armed
Forces during the interwar years and
into the second world war where two of
the most iconic machine guns of the time
was the British brand and the German
mg42 the Bren gun was based off the
checklist of vacuum zbvc26 it was
lighter and more maneuverable than many
other machine guns but its ability to
deploy sustained fire was limited by
their 20 round box magazines Gunner
teams did become very proficient in
magazine changes and the process of
reloading also allowed barrels to cool
meaning less Barrel swaps in the field
but brief pauses of fire could leave an
assaulting team vulnerable this issue
was less prevalent with the German belt
fed mg-42 but the system was much
heavier required more men to crew
efficiently and the rate of fire at
which they ate through ammunition meant
that more rounds would be required to
feed the weapon and despite there being
a quick change barrel system the weapon
overheating was still an issue
[Music]
but what about in our video games
in classic games like Contra picking up
a machine gun would often just simply
allow you to hold the fire button down
and fill the screen with colorful
damaging pixels while in Wolfenstein 3D
what the game calls a machine gun was a
straight upgrade to the pistol once
again providing the player the option
for more damage and automatic fire
for much of the timeline of video games
the machine gun was simply more bullets
faster in so many campaigns a light
machine gun gave players the option to
dial up the action lean into the spray
and pray play style and create intense
set pieces where you're defending a
position or firing from a vehicle
but ashute has developed and started to
feature a greater variety of weapons it
became more and more important that each
of those types were balanced and felt
varied in their handling and utility
especially when it came to multiplayer
something that's very difficult to kind
of account for in games is sheer weight
of a of a light machine gun of any era
the trend is very much toward lighter
especially when rifle caliber ammunition
becomes small caliber High Velocity like
5.56 that does reduce the burden of the
machine gunner but still that that's
still a hefty bit of kit it's always
going to be heavier than a rifle of the
same caliber
foreign
that's very hard to get across typically
games will just give you a movement
penalty while you have it equipped the
more mil Sim type games might give you
that penalty just for carrying it which
is obviously more realistic but a bit
frustrating that's one of the key ways
to differentiate the thing and make it
not just a you know assault rifle with a
ridiculous magazine the distinction
between an assault rifle and a light
machine gun is an important one to make
with many developers being careful that
a machine gun doesn't steal the job of
an automatic rifle or vice versa the
magazine and rate of fire of a light
machine gun offers a huge advantage to
players offering the potential of
sustained fire and easier multi-kills
especially if your stream of bullets can
penetrate cover of course the drawback
there is that a belt is much slower to
reload than a magazine but in many games
that just simply isn't enough of a
downside as you've either got the cover
of allies and obstacles or you've died
and are already respawning just a few
meters away with a refreshed gun anyway
or in the case of Rainbow Six Siege
where lmgs Ruled The Meta for months in
20 22 you could visibly kill every
member of the team in a 5v5 without ever
having the need to reload it's fairly
common to see lmgs having Nerfs to their
recoil Mobility bullet spread reload
speed and sometimes even damage with
some like machine guns even doing
different damage than the assault rifles
that fire the same caliber sometimes
these Nerfs can go so far that the lmg
can be outclassed by weapons like SMGs
and assault rifles this can be
understandable at close ranges where
your maneuverability is slow and your
hip fire has a snowball's chance in hell
at hitting your enemy but these Nerfs
have felt even at medium ranges where in
theory the virtual like machine gun
should Excel most of all as Shooters
progressed more customization was
offered to players wanting to Tinker
with their weapons but instead of adding
something like a bipod an accessory
pretty essential to the efficient use of
the real world lmg players would often
favor options that would minimize the
downsides of the light machine gun to
better fit a game's meta slapping on or
tearing off parts to make the lmg feel
more like an assault rifle just with
more bullets while these changes can
often make it feel like the weapon loses
some of its identity both in form and in
its function a certain amount is
necessary less the lmg simply become a
super assault rifle even if deep down
many of us want that virtual fantasy of
being the bullet spewing army of One a
Battle Cry in our chest a machine gun in
one hand and belt of ammunition slung
over the other the classic Rambo now
this is something that the more I've
learned about the the history of the use
of the machine gun in Warfare the more
it turns out people have actually done
that brand Gunn in Malaya and Borneo it
was a sort of designated weapon for that
role either far from the shoulder or
fire from the hip because of the close
quarters of the Jungle it was less of a
concern that your accuracy would not be
great which it won't be if you're firing
especially from the hip there aren't
many light machine guns you can fire
from the shoulder with any kind of
degree of accuracy I'd be absolutely
appalling at it I'm not built for it
there's certainly are soldiers who are
built for it so typically your Brenner
or whatever it won't be would be issued
to someone with the strength to actually
not only carry around all day but to
deploy it in that kind of fashion if
you're needing it in the assault you're
needing it to break contact in a jungle
Ambush or something you would absolutely
do that what you wouldn't do is fire it
one-handed and the whole supporting the
ammunition belt with the other hand is
really just rule of cool in a way
logical that he that he held it like
that but you'd never want to sacrifice
the other hand off the gun and yeah you
have to be at least as built as Stallone
circa 1985 and there aren't that many
soldiers who are that strong
many games have made concessions to fit
them into the ecosystem of their
multiplayer arsenals While others will
offer the light machine gun a use Beyond
just racking up kills or giving enemy
snipers someone easy to shoot
suppressive fire is defined as fire that
degrades the performance of an enemy
Force below the level needed to fulfill
its Mission basically people inherently
don't want to get hit by a bullet and
will instinctively put their head down
or duck away to avoid that it is a huge
part of the lmg's history and place on
the real world battlefield but how do
you portray the feeling of not wanting
to be shot in a virtual experience that
simply allows you to respawn this has
often left suppression mechanics feeling
as confused as the weapons themselves
the first times I can remember utilizing
suppression as a mechanic was in games
like full spectrum warrior in 2004 or
the brothers and arms Series in 2005
while each of their gameplay and
settings were different at their core
there was a focus on suppression fire
and movement the RTS Company of Heroes
also has a suppression mechanic where
infantry will become pinned down if
taking incoming rapid fire and are
unable to break away or find cover
programming AI to take cover and fire
blindly is one thing but trying to apply
a similar effect to a real human player
is another altogether an early and
Infamous example of this was with the
launch of Battlefield 3. almost all
weapons could apply suppression of
course it was easier with the heavier
volume of fire and lmg offered but
regardless of source the effects were
intense your vision would blur your
scope would sway your accuracy would
plummet and your character would even
scream for help it was somewhat
effective as simulated suppression but
it was also so distracting and annoying
to deal with especially in a mainstream
shooter as the franchise continued
suppression was a little different in
each game while sharing the general
effects of inhibiting your Target's
accuracy and senses the mechanic was
more focused on machine Gunners and
heavy weapons with Battlefield 5 having
its own machine gun a combat role
specializing in suppression the lmg
being tied to a support class made a lot
of sense in the battlefield series as it
gave players a reason to keep that
Medium distance where the weapon excels
while also having extra responsibilities
like supplying ammunition using mortars
or building fortifications Battlefield
also gave an important incentive for
applying suppressive fire to support
your team in the form of suppression
kill assists as well as the accumulative
ribbons and medals while suppression in
Battlefield has been a debated topic
across the franchise its utility means
that it is all the more baffling that
Battlefield 2042 a game with the largest
maps in the franchise chose to Omit this
feature these little rewards meant that
support players were more likely to
engage in suppressing fire team play and
the role of the lmg rather than simply
waiting for the kill shot themselves
from the games I've played the
suppression in more strategic or
hardcore titles have much deeper effects
on both tactics and player experience
the armor series is one of the most
popular military Sim franchises and
through the series Bohemia has aimed to
make the experiences as authentic as
possible the Armor 3 Marksman DLC
introduced bipods and AI suppression
meaning the players are able to add
further tactile flexibility to their
weapons and operations as the AI enemies
would duck for cover hit the deck and
struggle to return effective fire
tactical FPS games like hell that loose
or Squad have much more focus on their
suppression systems when compared to
more mainstream titles where players
under Fire will feel more intense audio
and visual feedback as well as being
less effective when returning fire
Insurgency Sandstorm adds more utility
to their automatic fire as well as their
lmgs through suppression most
prominently felt in the attack and
defend game modes a player's Vision will
tunnel somewhat their ears may ring
their ability to aim suffers and their
character will even scream and panic
escape from tarkov might be pretty light
on the amount of lmgs they offer right
now and in terms of gameplay mechanics
the suppression effect is a little more
subtle but much more intense is the
effect being suppressed can have on the
individual player themselves as tarkov
can be a very punishing game where one
bullet can cause you to lose all your
gear Quest progress or time invested on
that raid the idea of dying even
virtually is a much stronger emotional
Force
but in some ways the effect is more
subtle than others it is nonetheless
interesting that games like tarkov
suppress the player While others
suppress the character in this genre it
can only take a few bullet hits to take
a player down a death can have a much
larger impact on both the team in-game
or on the player themselves from long
respawn times and a long commute to the
front lines to the player losing a
character or equipment these are
psychological ways that by Design or not
can add potency to the suppression
system and in turn why lmgs and
suppression Works more in the Tactical
sphere of games even titles like Foxhole
an action-based strategy MMO adds
broader utility to the light machine
guns through leaning a little more into
their real world application and effects
allowing huge number of players to
utilize coordinated fire and advanced
tactics or suppress enemy bunkers and
trenches these games are also played for
the experience and feeling of them with
impactful and intense sound and visual
design further immersing the players
into that virtual Battlefield experience
it's my belief that the more a player is
on immersed the easier it is for
elements like suppression or the
Tactical use of a light machine gun to
make sense to the player but also be
felt by them while the nmg has often
struggled to find its place within games
with its portrayals varying potentially
more than any other weapon type its
variety means that it has found a place
on a broad spectrum of video games both
Gamers and developers understand the
appeal and important Variety in gameplay
a light machine gun can offer they're an
exciting weapon to add to your Loadout
so it makes sense that some titles have
tweaked its power level to fit more
neatly into their fast-paced games While
others may choose to lean more into
reality and let the nmg fire away loud
and free the strategy and application
that a player with an lmg in a milsim
shooter can be just as satisfying and
rewarding as getting a quad feed with
your belt fed in Call of Duty or
Battlefield and for every action hero
campaign arcade FPS or Arena shooter
we're starting to see more realistic
depictions of battles tactics and of
course the light machine gunner
thank you so much for watching this
episode of Loadout I hope you enjoyed
this look at one of the most fun if
maybe a little underrepresented guns in
our games if you did make sure to like
the video leave your thoughts in the
comment section below and of course
subscribe for the rest of the series let
us know what you'd like to see future
episodes cover and if you want more
video game Firearms content you can
watch the previous episode of this show
or check out our weekly series of
firearms expert reacts where I show our
friends the Royal armories a selection
of guns from our favorite games until
next time I've been your host Dave
DeWitt thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you